yeah this video is brought to you by the
color blue everywhere my shirt
background
a lot of blue but i had to play i was a
man with a plan i was all gearing up to
get ready to do a video on the original
taken and then the
blasphemous dlc came out i kind of got
wrapped into that
and then by the time i was like okay i
really got to do this now there's
there's a trailer for the boys and i
want to talk about the boys i love the
boys i figure i could talk about this
because it's got to be a pinocchio joke
or a jonah joke that i could
make somehow i'm not going to now
but it could happen god in pinocchio
that well freaked me out didn't he freak
you out he's all freaking out
[Music]
nightmares i'm telling you kids
shouldn't watch that [ __ ] parents you
let your kids watch pinocchio at a young
age
this is as normal as they get to be
don't do it so anyhow the boys season
two we have a new trailer it's like
it feels like just yesterday i talked
about the teaser trailer now we have
what's called the final trailer the
final trailer before the actual final
trailer that they're inevitably going to
drop it's like we always get a final
trailer and then
a launch trailer but it looks like
butcher and his friends the spice girls
are at it again because all right
spoiler for
you've seen season one whatever he found
out his wife is alive he's like all
right we got to take these dicks down
and there's a new one what was the name
stormchaser or something
hi i'm stormfront stormfront
that's her name i figured stormchaser i
was like that's cheesy even for me let
me double check it looks like homelander
feels like she is stepping on his toes
though maybe
because she's getting a bit of the
limelight maybe it's because she's
taking his grand villain scheme
regardless i'm the new girl wonderful
making an assessment
that was not sincere however no don't be
a [ __ ] laser my [ __ ] tits
cheers to the best scene of the trailer
he did laser them titties but even
though he did laser them titties i hope
they don't push homelander to the side
and
make him as she said a little bit i'm
all for a new villain but i just hope
that
homeland are still the main the main
villain you know no one ended the boys
season one with well i hope we see less
homelander next season i bring this up
because
i've seen crazier things also i love the
fact that giancarlo esposito
is in this show not only so i can
mispronounce his name
inevitably or at least lazily pronounce
this my way i mean with love i just i
love him i love
him and i love the fact that so many
shows games movies properties they're
all like all right
we need him we need a villain who's
really gonna come to the forefront
get him get him get him get him every
time
i wonder how he's gonna bring it though
he's so menacing and intimidating in a
lot of other roles i've seen him in but
i loved elizabeth shue in this show in
the sense that she was so good at
handling the public she was all about
public image and
the people in entertainment industry
that's what they're like honest no
upfront uh-uh straightforward absolutely
not
but like her they are i've said it i
said it before i'll say it again i'm
looking forward to the boys in cobra
kai's season three this is this is what
i'm looking forward to i will give you
that review of season two
before cobra kai's season three drops i
feel like dropping a review for cobra
kai season two
on the heels of season three's premiere
i feel like that's just a bit smarter so
that is what i wait for now you know
regardless man the boys one month away i
can't wait
because kano i'm just saying and eobard
thawne
in the movie should be shows a little
more on new characters shows that
they're expanding on the plot that
homelander built up in the last one you
know the big reveal where he's like oh i
have this huge evil scheme they all know
the same thing if you want to be the
savior you got to create the problem so
you can swoop in with the solution
that's
just the way the world works one thing i
love more than heroes fighting villains
it's villains fighting villains when the
villains pose as heroes but they're
actually villains alright so the final
trailer for the boys season 2 have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you